the final diplomatic drive to get a new
deal on brexit
Rishi sunak arriving in Windsor can you
sell the deal sir
this a prime minister looking to achieve
what his predecessors could not
welcome in the European commission
president Ursula Von de Lyon is a new
era of relations
in what they hope will be a reset moment
all smiles wants more between old allies
this deal months in the making I know it
hasn't always been easy at times but we
have got through it
a new PM a new approach and a new deal
for Northern Ireland
I'm pleased to report
that we have now made a decisive
breakthrough
together
we have changed the original protocol
and are today announcing the New Windsor
framework
I believe the Windsor framework marks a
turning point for the people of Northern
Ireland
symbolic Moment underpinned by tangible
Solutions green and red lanes for smooth
the trade between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland
this means we have removed any sense of
a border in the Irish sea
a so-called storment break allowing
Northern Ireland politicians to reject
EU laws
this gives the institutions of the Good
Friday agreement in Northern Ireland a
powerful new Safeguard based on
cross-community consent
and powers for the UK to set vat rules
in Northern Ireland from the commission
president notable warmth
the New Windsor framework is here to
benefit people in Northern Ireland
and support all communities celebrating
peace on the island of Ireland
and this is why I believe we can now
open a new chapter in our partnership
stronger EU UK relationship
standing as close Partners shoulder to
shoulder now and in the future
prime minister you worried this will
split your party
the immediate future for this PM selling
the deal to the dup and his own MPS so
what's your message to brexiteers sir
it's a very good deal for the people of
Northern
those brexiteers in support were out in
force today
I would resign if I felt I couldn't
support the deal so you know I'm backing
this with a good heart this is much
better than boris's deal from the
sovereignty point of view from a trade
point of view from a democracy point of
view it's better but in the House of
Commons still questions the PM biting
his lips as he waited for the verdict of
the dup in Broad terms it is clear that
significant progress has been secured
across a number of areas whilst also
recognizing that there remain key issues
of concern could I remain the Prime
Minister that although he talks about
1700 pages of EU law being removed from
Northern Ireland hundreds of thousands
of pages will still remain can he
understand why we don't have confidence
in that and why we still fear that the
our position within the United Kingdom
is not going to be restored by this
agreement
a day of careful choreography the
commissioned president arriving at
Windsor Castle for an audience with the
King but for all the days delicate
diplomacy tonight the deal's still not
agreed brexit has been one of Britain's
most significant post-war decisions and
the attempt by Mr sunac to try to break
the impasse in Northern Ireland will
undoubtedly go down as one of the most
profound moments in his own leadership
succeed and this caretaker prime
minister suddenly becomes a far more
credible one fail and he could see his
Premiership sink farther still
inside number 10 they think the gamble
will pay off only time will tell Beth
Rigby Sky News